皆さんこんにちは
私は世耕一弘と申します今関西の私立大学
で
経営戦略本部長という役を
仰せつかってますであの大学で主に
いろんな仕事やってるんですけど広報畑が
非常に長くていろいろ大学の情報を発信
することとかを主な仕事としてこうやって
きてますで大学といえばですね一応我々の
業界では高等教育機関とも言われたりとか
例えば最高楽譜これ最高額ってみんな東京
のとある一番難しい入試の難しい大学
ちゃうかみたいに言われるんですけど実は
大学っていうのは一応この
教育機関としては最高楽譜と言われている
ところで私は
働いております
比較的経営の中の非常に重要な部分を担わ
せていただいているわけなんですけれども
自分の話をちょっとカミングアウトします
けれどもこういう期間で私は働いてます
けども
非常に勉強が嫌いでした生まれてから
ずっと嫌いで
小学校3年生ぐらい比較的ちょっと恵まれ
た環境だったと思うんですけれども小学校
3年生ぐらいからもう塾に入れられて中学
受験が必須の家庭だったんです今から
考えると本当にさっきも言いましたけれど
も恵まれた環境ではあったんですけれども
私にとってはずっと地獄でしたまだ当時は
小学校3年生人クラス30人か40人の
ところで
塾なんか言ってるか2人か3人ぐらいしか
いなかったんでなんで俺だけ行かされんの
やろうっていうのずっと思ってたら勉強に
関するモチベーションが全くないままこう
進んでた時にある時ですねこのままやっ
たらこいつはダメやということで親から
エスカレーター式っていうのがあるの知っ
てるかと
中学受験したらあと高校受験も大学受験も
なしでそのまま大学に行けるそういう
仕組みがこの世の中にあるんやと何それ
かなり面白いで実際中学
入学したらそこからあんまり勉強せんでも
ええよあんまり勉強せんでよって聞いて
たら僕からしたらもう全く勉強せんでええ
よっていう風にだったら今から僕は勉強し
てやると頑張って
6年生ぐらいから見事入学を勝ち取って
その時の
春休みのエピソードなんですけど本当に今
から思った恥ずかしい話なんですけど僕は
もうこれで勉強せんでいいやと思って
テレビつけてドラえもんかなんかこう見て
たんですけどもそして母親が何気にこう僕
のところにまあとりあえず春休み入った
これぐらいやっときって言ってなんか英語
のaとかBとかCをなぞって書くなんか
ペンマシップって昔あったんですけども
小学生ぐらいはやるやつですけどこれ
ぐらいちょっとやっときなさいって言われ
た時僕はもう涙流しながらこう激怒したん
です
騙したともう勉強せんでって言ったやない
か
とてで中学入るんですけどまぁそんなに
甘くないのもこう分かりながら一応中学
からこう怖がるのも何人かを落とされたり
とかしててそこには引っかかりたくない
から最後送ったアクセル踏み込んでそこ
からスッと上がる大学進学する時もずっと
こう通知部にこうキー信号って書かれてて
というかもうどことは言えませんけどうち
のその学校はですねほとんど全員上に
上がれるなんか300何十人によって20
人ぐらい上がられへんっていう環境なんで
だいたいその300万ぐらいにいるんです
けど最後油になったらちょっとアクセル
踏んだらキュッとこう上がっていける
ところでなんとか切り抜けて大学に入り
ます
でも大学入ってもそんなに勉強にこう
モチベーションがなく唯一私日本史だけは
好きだったんでもうそういう歴史学科
みたいなところにこう言っててそれは感覚
はあってたんですけどそれでも勉強に身が
入るわけではなくてただ多分勉強嫌い
正しい数年後には4年後には社会で出
なきゃいけないそんなところで会社入っ
たりとかすると多分優秀な人がたくさん
いるやろなとでこの頭で勝負してても多分
勝手にやろうからっていうのもあって大学
からのブドウ系の大会のクラブに入ったり
とかイベントサークルやったりとか
いろんな経験積みながらそれはそれで後に
素晴らしい体験になっていくわけなんです
けども
大学を卒業して会社に入るという
ストーリーなんですでこういうこと言うの
本当に私的には勇気がいるんです高等教育
機関に行って中ではこう学生向けには
とにかく勉強しなさいとかうちらの附属
学校もたくさんあるんだけど付属の頃集め
てとにかくやっぱり今勉強は今しかでき
ないですとかって言いながら自分が最も
究極的にこう勉強が嫌いだったというこう
いう自分の過去をここでカミングアウトし
てますそんな私ですけれどもちょっと要領
良かったんでしょうねまあ入社試験とかは
こうなんとかこう通ってですね
関西の私鉄業界にこうで働きますで関西の
施設
業界で私はどっちか様あんまりこう手元で
こうもの書いたりと計算する仕事より
ちょっと体使う仕事のが向いてるなと思っ
て自分でも死亡してすぐにホテルの方に
こう出向してホテルマンとして7年半いて
かつ途中
海外にも派遣してもらったりとかして
いろんないい経験をさせてもらってそこ
から私は次に自分のまぁ生涯の仕事になる
ような広報というものに出会えますそれは
鉄道本社の広報担当として
移動になりましてそこで色んな体験をする
んですけれども
プレスリリース書いたりとかたまに謝罪
会見やったりとかいろいろテレビにとか
新聞に情報を発信する仕事です非常に承認
あっててすごく楽しかったんですけれども
その中でまだそんなにですね重要視されて
なかったいわゆるインターネット特に
私たちの会社のホームページを私がこう
担当することになりましたで今だったら
多分あれぐらいの会社のホームページって
言ったら何も担当してると思うんです
けれどもなんかほんと片手間程度の感じで
こうやられてて例えばすごい面白いこう
いう情報発信できる仕事面白いなっていう
ことでホームページとかをこうやってて
少しでもアクセス伸ばせるようなことを
考えてたんですけれども
合わせて他にも鉄道の候補ですごい重要な
ことが
列車事故とか例えば台風で列車が遅延し
ますとかっていうともうすっごいマスコミ
からも問い合わせかかってきますけどもう
お客さんからも電話すごいんですでもう駅
の現場なんかもう台風がこう来てまだ当時
何も情報発信されてないNHKで若干そこ
でこう流れテロップでこう流れてる情報
ぐらい以外もうみんな電車乗って止まっ
たら何が起きた副作用わからない環境でで
ただスマガラケーだけはもう全ての人が
持ってる時代
でもとにかく
昔そんなかかってこなかったんですけども
その20数年前はガラケーをみんな持っ
てるから
めっちゃかかってくる環境で電話は回線
パンクするしやっと繋がってもお客さん
怒り狂ってるしそれをずっとこう聞いてて
ある時ふと気づいて当時あのガラケーでも
インターネットにアクセスできるように
なってたんでこんな情報別に
ネットに出したらええやんっていう本当に
当たり前のことでよう考えてみたらお客
さんも台風で遅れたこととか事故で遅れた
ことに起こってるわけじゃなくてもこれ
からどうしたらいいねいつ復旧すんねん
肉球する見込みあるんかっていうことを
知りたいけど情報が全くないから
怒り狂うこれも情報を出すだけで多分
いろんな人のこうストレスっていうのは
軽減できるやろという風に思って当たり前
のことは僕からしたらどう考えてもこれで
会社をかなり良くできるなんてええないか
と思って
鉄道にそういう運行情報ホームページに
運行情報を流そうという話を持ちかけたら
ですねまあ当時のお偉いさんからですね
めちゃくちゃ
怒られたんです
ざけるなと
列車が遅れるっていうのは鉄道会社の
理由のいかんによらず鉄道の恥じない現場
は必死で1分でも早く回復するために全力
を上げてんのにそれを広報はお前情報
バーンとインターネットって誰でも見れる
のやろうっていうから誰でも見れますって
もう日本どころじゃなくて世界中の人も
見れますふざけんな電車に乗りも選手たち
に生まれそんな情報を出すんかとでこれ別
に当時の体制批判してるわけじゃなくて
理由の以下によらずもう僕からしたら
ホテルから
鉄道に変わってきたんで
台風で列車が遅れるとか事故で例えば車が
こう踏切に入って
立ち往生してますそういう理由で送れる
なんて別にええやんって別にこっち悪く
ないねんからっていう感じので思ってたん
ですけどやっぱり鉄道のプロっていうのは
そういうことを
理由の一環によらず鉄道のアジアという
ことでやってるそれが当時の鉄道の常識
だったふざける出すなということで一旦
クローズされたんですけれどもその後
ちょっと鉄道会社でもお客様サービス向上
とか真剣に取り組むようになっている
ところでいろいろ頭の下げ方とかやってる
一家の中にやっぱりこれやった方がいい
ですよっていうことを
持ちかけてなんとか通ってできたんですで
当時は私の考えてることはお前なんて非
常識なやつやってこう言われてまあ確かに
そうかなと思ってたんですけれども今見て
ください
鉄道会社のホームページとかで運行情報を
出さない会社があるかって言ったらない
ですそして
そういうさっきみたいな鉄道会社のアジア
から出さへんって言ったら会社があったと
したらみんな多分なんて
非常識な会社という風に思われると思い
ますその時に思ったのは本当に自分一人で
ふと思って私別にそんなに高尚な考え方
持ってたりとかここで一肌上げたろうと
思ってるわけじゃなくて本当にさっくり
こんな
ネットであったらいいじゃないですか
みたいな感じがですね
激動されて非常識やったんですけどどっか
を境目にコロっとこう入れ替わる体験をし
たんです数年後にはもうどこの鉄道会社も
それ入れてのが当たり前になってきてて別
に自慢もしません別に僕インターネットの
テクノロジーを分かってるわけでも何でも
なくって普通にある情報
技術を
サクッとちょっと使っただけのことやった
んですけれどもそういうふうにこう世の中
転換していくという体験をしてその他
いろんな経験もしましたけれどもそういう
面白い仕事としてそしてやって大学の方に
行きますそして私が一番初めに配属された
のが
入試事務部入試広報かあれだけ人生から
逃れてきたあれが嫌で生きてきた入試って
いうのが自分の名刺の中に2回乗ってなん
かもらった時に感慨深いなとでもう入試の
ことは全くわからないちょうど当時の
センター試験がやってる最中に一緒に
合わせて準備しててやりながら若い子に
ごめんこれセンター入試って何のための
試験なんて
聞いたことない何でセンター何のセンター
やねんみたいな感じで話を言ってて
わからんままこう突入していくんです
けれどもまあこれ入試っていうのは多分
苦労して受験された方にとってはすっごい
神聖なもんだと思いますもうそういう感じ
がこうありありとしてきてるけど僕には何
もわからないそしたらある時バンっと渡さ
れたのが願書ビリビリったわけでこんな
分厚いところにスッと抜いたら薄いピンク
色でこうマークシートばっと書く出願票
ってあるんですけど
パッと見てこれ何ってこれ願書ですよとで
せこさんこれ願書しっかりちょっと勉強し
てくださいとでこれ間違うともう大変な
ことになるから受験生に指導するときとか
でもこことこうやってこう乗っててうちの
大学当時でももう13学部47学科入試は
日本で一番多い12日間試験会場は全国
30何箇所でやってるんでもう
びっしり書いてここ多分私が勉強好きな
人間だったらそれ持ち帰ってあの入試を
こうっても一生あんなもん読まへんって
いうぐらいのやつをずらーっと読んで勉強
したと思うんですけどもう残念ながらそう
いう気がしなくてその瞬間を
ネットでやったらSSやんってで
言った時の周りの反応がえって
さすがに入試は
願書は手書きで書かせましょうよっていや
字の綺麗さとか点数にするんやってええ
けどもこんな別に結構まあまあみんなも
こう殴り書きしてる状態でと思った時に
パッと思ったらこの人らなんか入手が
願書は手書きで書かなあかんという常識に
縛られてるんやなとそっからいろんな大学
の人と話してもいやーそれはもうニュース
はもう感謝の手書きでみたいなで何でって
聞いてもいやそういうもんですみたいな話
があってあこれは面白いなとそこにもう一
つ私並行して大学の子を入手広告とかを
改革していくようなこともやってましたで
その背景には何かって言ったらもう大学は
めちゃくちゃ
社用産業なんです18歳人口が1992年
には205万人いたんですこれ大昔じゃ
ないです私が大学出た時ぐらいなんで
そんなに私の中で昔やと思ってないんです
けれどもそして私が大学に入った時には
124万人そして今年で11ものすごい
勢いで減ってきてますで2038年には
98万人2040年の88万円もう
マーケットからこんだけ対象が消えて
しまう40年間でマイナス117%-5%
ここまでこう減っちゃう世界に
我々は突入していかなければならないだ
から増えていくときであればそのままの
ことやっといたら良かったんですけども
減っていく段階であれば何か変えていか
なきゃいけないということでまず私は大学
の入試の常識をぶっ壊していこうという
ことで例えば大学の広告っていうのは
とにかく教育研究の内容をしっかり出し
といたらそれで受験生が来るんやっていう
風に言われてたんですけどほんまにそうか
と予備校とかいろんな高等学校回っても僕
が痛い目にあったのはとにかくうちの教育
研究の内容の話聞いてもらおうと思っても
そこの担当の人らはすいませんお宅の大学
はちょっとうちの志望校の対象じゃないん
です話しさえ何も聞いてくれただ僕らは
その予備校からうちの大学受けて何人受け
て何人落ちたか持ってるんです
十分落ちてるん全然あなた方の学校通って
ないですで入試の制度をもうちょっと
担当者が理解してくれた登録もいたのに
ねっていう思いで言ってるんですけど
門前払いされていってまあ世の中理想で
あればその教育研究の内容を見て大学を
選んでくるこれが正しい世界ではあります
けれども現実そうではないここで大学出て
いられる方入っておられる方自分が大学を
受ける時にそこの大学のちょっとしたこと
は調べると思うんですけれども教員の論文
とかそんなん取り寄せてみましたか何とか
先生っているんであれば本書いておられる
んでそれ見てその本に対して自分の意見と
かを郵便で送ったりとかしてその先生と
こうやり取りしてってこれが理想やと思う
んですけどそういうことではないで僕は別
に売れてるわけじゃなくてそれが現実だ
からそのためにどうしていくかっていうと
とにかくまあインパクトのある広告を出し
ていくようなことを考えていって例えば
マグロ大学って言うてるやつ誰やとか
富士山からダンと出てきてるとかここに
対した意味ではないんですただインパクト
をつけて何か面白そうな大学だってやっ
たら今度はインターネットで相当詳しい
情報を検索してもらえる世の中になってき
たんで私はこういうところでやってたで
この辺りも大学の常識ぶっ壊して今から見
たら別にどってことないんですけどもう
その時はもう近代的でも黒たんかみたいな
ことをこう言われてたんですけどいや
みんなはもう校門の前になんか生徒が立っ
てなんか輝く未来がここから始まるとか
確かな教養を身につけたグローバル人材を
世界へ発信した動画みたいなこうもう大学
名書いたらどこの大学でも使えるやないか
みたいなコピーばっかりやってたんで
インパクトをつけて
認知をしてもらってあとは時代が
インターネットになったから細かい情報は
そこで引っ張ってもらえるということに
なりましたそして次にやったのがそれだけ
でも足りないこの近畿大学を世の中に
とにかく確信新しいことにどんどん
チャレンジするキャラクターということを
知らしめていくために普通インターネット
であったりとか色々やったりが教育の研究
の中身やったやったんですけど一番受験生
が手にするものを変えてやろうということ
で
完全インターネット出願ということで
踏み切っていきました当時受験生保護者
そして学校の先生もうみんな大反対です誰
もしてほしくない今まで通りやっといて
くれたらお兄ちゃん時計せっかくお母さん
覚えたからもう弟の時もこのままやれんの
にとかもう先生をみんな思ってたんです
けれども
あえてやりましたこれなぜかというと僕に
は何の根拠もなくって絶対そうした方が
ええわっていうことで気づいたのとみんな
この世界で大学の世界で何か頭縛られてる
受験は神聖なもんやから頭縛られてんねん
なと後はスマートフォンでチャチャチャと
海外の情報を調べていったらあの
ハーバードであのスタンフォードでさえも
あのオックスフォードさえももっともの昔
からインターネットでしか出願できなく
なってきてるんですそんな情報は別に本も
開かないです
論文も読まないですスマホでチャチャチャ
と見てたらだいたいわかってくるメキシコ
とかインドネシアとかそういう国でも
インターネットからしかやってないです
日本だけなんか郵便事情めちゃくちゃ
いいんでもうポストに入れたら絶対届くと
思い込んでるできるこれインドネシアとか
いっぱい島あるような国でポストに物を
入れて確実に届くかアメリカさえでも
そんなことはないとこやったんで日本は
ちょっと遅れてたけどこれ確実にいずれ
それに変わるわということでやりました
ただしもう周りも大反対みんな大反対でし
たけれども思い切ってやってみて結果は
ですねこの2013年にやったんです
けれども市販者数が一時期僕らも7万人
ぐらいまで落ち込んでた時期があったん
ですけれども一気に増えていったんですで
この
2013年ぐらいの時にですね12年
インターネットがやりますという時に新聞
にはもう絶対失敗するとその受験生は神で
出したいに決まってるとインターネットに
もいずれ変わるかもしれへんけどそれ5年
10年変わんねやって立って変わんねやっ
てやっててただし僕らがバンとやった人間
現金なもんですいろんな大学もあんだけ僕
らのことバカにしてたのに志願者激増させ
た瞬間にですね
翌年から一気にこうインターネット出願に
なだれ込んでいって私はいまだにその新聞
をずっとあのパソコンの中入れて定期的に
見るんですけど2012年には
インターネット出願には時間かかる
2013年の新聞にはインターネット出願
もう普通ってこう書いて一気にこう転換し
ていくまさにこの鉄道でも体験した経験が
できたと思いますでこれまた面白いことに
ですね何の関係もないです私別に学術の
情報とか必死に発信するというよりは
とにかく注目を集めていってあとはWeb
ページにこう引っ張ってくってことやった
だけだったんですけれどもこの年から志願
者数が日本一になって今10年連続2本1
という形になってますで私何名もいますが
テクノロジーなんか全く分かってません
高等教育のなんか語ろうと言っても語れる
フリぐらいはもうできるようになりました
けど正直わかってないですまして私の働い
てる大学っていうのは医学部から
芸術系の学科まであるんでもう教育語り
出したらもう何十通りのこと話せなかっ
たら語れないで私はそういうこと語らない
んですけれどもまあ広報戦略とかこうやっ
てイメージ戦略でそれがいいのか悪いのか
わかんないですけどただ見られた通り人口
がこんだけ減する時には何か手を打た
なければ
志願者が減る
定員割れるそしたら大学っていうのは確実
に潰れていくんです今日本の大学の40%
が定員割れしてて日本の大学の40%が
赤字経営になっていってるただ今の段階で
これですからいずれ90万人80万人台に
入っていくってなったらもう何が起きるか
分かりますよねもう理想を語ってる場合
じゃなくてやっぱり自分の仕事の中で
できることだけをしっかりやってくる最初
私にあったことは別にすっごい
テクノロジーを持ち込んだわけでもなくて
普通に世の中にあるもんをポンと入試の
世界に持ってきたりとかいろんな業界が
やってる広告のものの考え方をポンと持っ
てきたそれだけなんですで自分でも思っ
てるんですほんとしょうもないことやっ
てるのになと思いながらもですねコロナ前
とか私年間100回ぐらいいろんなとこで
講演させてもらったりもうこんなペットの
場にこんな呼んでもらえる要するにまぁ
ちょっとした常識をですねこう覆していく
だけでいろんなチャンスいろんな人と私は
こう出会えるようになっていたことを
嬉しく思ってますそしてまだまだ広報戦略
我々しっかりこうやっていかなきゃいけ
ないんですけれども最後私の個人の
野望を聞いてほしいんですけれども今
取り組んでいることがですねもうとにかく
今
教育研究もちろんそれは先生方が一生懸命
やってってもらってるけどそれ以上に何か
大学のリソースないかなってグッと見て
たら実は大学ってものすごいキャンパス
持ってるけれども年の半分ほぼ人がいない
んです土曜日日曜日もほとんど人がいない
ですそしてあの大学生だけの特権の
めちゃめちゃ長い
夏休みですねそして
冬休みをまあまあ長いもう春休みなんか
単位取ってる奴からしたらもう1月半ば
ぐらいからもう4月までほとんど学校混ん
で
空いてるあそこにですね学生が毎日もっと
来るような環境を作っていきたいという
ことで今やってることは例えば自習室は
365日に24時間空けていく世の中女性
は心配だろうから女性専用の自習室とか
やって例えば資格の勉強とかもそこでやっ
ていけたりとかあと学生の起業家を育成
するような施設作ってそこももう無意味に
とりあえず24時間開けていく今度4月
からコンビニもミニコンビニの無人の24
時間開けていくどんどんどんどん24時間
化させていくことによって大学周辺にです
ね1時間半とかかけて通ってくる子たちが
どんどんどんどん住み出してきたら大学に
こう人がどんどんどんどん増えてきて
そして土日にも24時間もずっと人がいる
となれば近隣の商店街とかもみんなこう
潤ってくるから街が
活性化してくるってそういうことを考えて
大学の24時間かっていうのこれから
どんどんどんどん
推し進めたいと思いますそんな学生が夜中
にうろうろするのかありえへんっていうか
もしれませんけれどももう答えはスマート
フォンを1個開いていろんな大学の子で
情報調べてったらアメリカの大学の事務
なんかほとんど24時間でアメリカの大学
の図書館なんかほとんど24時間学校の
周りにみんな住んで一体感持ってって
るっていう常識があるんですただ今は大学
の世界では
夏休みは人がいないも春休みは人がいない
もん年間半分だけの施設がほとんど人がい
ない世界を作り出しているのが
常識ですけれども今度近畿大学かそういう
常識を壊していってで私は何も近代だけが
勝ちたいんじゃなくていっぱいしんどい
思いしてる大学があるんですまあ確かに
ブランド校はそうではないかもしれない
けどそうじゃない大学とかもとにかくそう
いう教育とかそういうところに縛られずに
ですねもっと新しいことをいっぱいやっ
てったら大学が面白くなる大学が面白く
なるといろんな優秀な学生がもっともっと
集まってきてもしかしたら世界から集まっ
てくるかもしれないそして大学が発展し
てったら日本が変わる日本を成長さすため
にこういう常識に縛られずに面白いことを
コツコツそれもなんか壮大なことやらなく
ていいんです当たり前のことをポロっと
切り替えるだけでもいろんなチャンスが
広がってくるんではないかというふうに
思ってます私は少なくともさっき何度も
言いますけど優秀な人間ではありません
勉強も嫌いですだけど自分の感じた常識
っていうのを信じて推し進めていくと
意外とごろっと変わってそれが常識になっ
てくるこの私がインターネット出願を日本
の大学で一番初めに取り入れてその後に
いろんな大学がいっぱいこうやってきて
くれて
腰の重い京都大学ももうやっと10年
ぐらい遅れてこうやって最後はあと日本の
頂点の大学がインターネット出願になっ
たら面白いです私がやったことを声で変え
てたそれだけでもなんかすごい幸せな
気持ちになってまあそういうことも評価し
ていろんな人と出会えたりとか今日この場
に
招いていただいたりその先
常識を
ぶっ壊したその先にいろんな道が開けて
いくということを皆さんと共有させて
いただきましたどうもありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]